well i mean every candidate that's
running for any office
should exhaust every option before they
can see to ensure that every vote has
been
legally counted and i think the
president is exhausting all of those
uh remedies available to the him and
rightly so i mean
you have he in his case he had 72
million people vote for him
and in many of these states uh states
rather the
margin is too close to call or there's
concerns about how the vote was counted
and the president should exhaust his the
the legal options available to them and
can i just
one quick point that i think you made in
the introduction we have a system in the
united states the
the state's votes um the votes tallied
and then electors or
are assigned uh those electors then meet
on december 14th
to decide how they will cast their
ballots that's actually how the united
states government works
when it comes to choosing our president
so because
a foreign leader has called or because a
television network has decided
doesn't make it so in the state of
arizona for example
the president is down about 12 000 votes
95
of the vote is in of 3 million votes
cast
that means that you know there's roughly
150 000 votes out of a 12 000 vote
league there's well
plenty within that state alone those 11
electoral votes would shift if president
trump were to take the lead
so i think the point is is that the
system is made
to allow for time to occur uh to to
cali tally those ballots for electors to
meet um
just because a a television network or
media organization
decides that they want to project a
winner doesn't make it so
it's not just the one state that jay
biden is ahead and if you look at what
is going in pennsylvania he is
50 000 votes ahead there doesn't need to
be a recount does there
it's done
wait wait a second hold on first of all
it's i agree with you joe biden is ahead
and if he is declared the winner in
those states
then he should be you know inaugurated
this next president the electors will
cast their vote for him
but it's not up to you to make that
decision right there are votes out
those votes have a right to be counted
there are military bouts that haven't
been counted there's a supreme court
challenge
to ballots that were tallied after
election day on november 3rd
but it is not up to you or anyone else
in the media to make that decision
it is up to the voters in that state and
the secretary of state in pennsylvania
it's a democratic secretary of state
when they certify the election then
that's it but until then
it's not over because a bunch of media
folks decide that despite all those
votes not being called
that they have decided because of
somehow they have expertise in this area
that's not how it works despite what you
want of course
i mean would you be saying the same
thing if it was hillary clinton
who was saying that uh it's too close to
call there should be recounts
would you be saying the same thing
so i actually it's a good question
because in 2004 i served as an elector
from the state of virginia the
commonwealth of virginia
and i actually have been a big believer
well before that that the electors
by our system are actually the ones who
cast it so yes the question is and why
this is different and
for those people who may be just tuning
in to u.s elections for the first time
if a candidate concedes well then that's
up to them to do so so if they concede
to the other candidate and say you have
won i'm not going to contest this
election
that's up to them to do right and then
of course the the government can move
through its transition process
early because one of the two candidates
has conceded but in the year 2000
when george bush neither george bush nor
al gore conceded there was a 37 day
recount
but you know i i will tell you the same
you know i so yes i have been
on record since the early 2000s
explaining how this process works so i
think you picked the wrong guest to pull
that argument with
but the point about florida it doesn't
really apply to this we're talking about
500 votes or so back in in 2000 it's
very different to what
it's like again let me finish this
sir i'm asking the questions and also
custom dictates that the incumbent or
they do
lose then they move aside
yes and as soon as the votes are tallied
if he loses i think he should but he has
a
right under our system to ask that the
votes be counted
that's how it works and i get it in
florida it wasn't a question of how many
votes it was within the margin of error
so they both you know in that case al
gore actually tried to have military
ballots excluded
so you know it's interesting but the
point is is that the system is set up
to allow for a candidate to ask for a
recount if it's within a certain amount
or to pose a legal challenge
president trump has a right to do that
he's exercising that right
and as much as you and a lot of folks in
the media don't like it
that's not how the system works and just
because hillary clinton chose to concede
in 2016
doesn't mean donald trump does but
you're missing the point just because
as soon as the the vote is final and all
the votes are cast
and certified if president trump has
exhausted his legal options and isn't
the winner then he should step aside
and allow joe biden but until then he
has a right and frankly an obligation of
the 73 million people that voted for him
to do so it's not a question of whether
i like it or not i'm just observing the
democratic process
in the united states i mean in terms of
donald trump what is going on no but
you're not
you're not actually but i am but i am
but anyway let's move on
what is going on in donald trump's head
right you're saying you're you're you're
actually
no you know you're cheapening our
process you're cheapening the process
by acting as though that because media
organization real clear politics
which up until the other day was the
gold standard election hasn't called
arizona it hasn't called pennsylvania
it hasn't called georgia or alaska
somehow the media organizations
that all talked about what the real
clear politic
average was going up to the election
have looked at that same organization
are now not recognizing that they're not
calling this election
so my point is is that if you want to
pick off one or two
ma you know left-leaning organizations
in this country and
say that they've called it that's up to
them that's their decision
but those states have not certified the
vote and and to make it seem
as though the president is not accepting
defeat is a false narrative
he is waiting he has a right to wait
until the vote is certified
but many would say that is donald trump
who and his lawyers who were cheapening
the um electoral process
any other candidate would have would
have stepped aside if donald trump
does lose and there are real questions
that's really interesting donald trump
let me finish please sir again i'm
asking the question
if donald trump does eventually step
aside he does eventually concede
what is likely to happen can you see him
running again in 2024
well i mean he he is uh the the biggest
factor in the republican party right now
he has every you know he'd have a right
to do it he has a huge following and the
base is rock solid
um you know he would definitely be the
front runner in 2024 there's no question
about it
and what about the future of the
republican party because it has
fundamentally changed
yeah and if you look at what we did in
the house of representatives we picked
up seats
when all the same folks in the media
said that the house was going to get a
drubbing
it looks like we'll keep control the
senate again the media projected
horrible outcomes on that the president
actually grew his popular vote
by of large margins considering the
narrative was that he was going to get
killed
he was stronger with hispanics stronger
with african americans stronger with
uh with jewish americans all groups that
the media said were going to run from
him
so i mean i i think that he is actually
when you look at vote totals it doesn't
match the narrative
that the u.s media was definitely trying
to portray leading up to this election
we actually did better in state house
races all around so the republican party
has actually done better and is stronger
coming out of this election
and looking at the united states right
now from this side of the atlantic i
think it's clear to everyone that the
country is extremely polarized now
um once the dust finally does settle
if donald trump does concede in the
coming weeks
will you rally behind president-elect
joe biden
how does a country get back together
well look i mean i i think that first of
all i i you know my view is i respect
our democratic process i've always
believed that once you know our we
settle our differences at elections and
then we respect the office
until the next election but i do think
that there's a difference here that's
the president who needs to set the tone
not me i mean i respect the office uh
whoever's in it i've watched i've been
in this game uh through democrats and
republicans i respect
people who win elections and then i
believe that you go out and you settle
your differences at the next one if you
don't like them
but i gotta be honest with you it's joe
biden who talks about unity
and yet everything that he's talked
about he's calling for unity and yet
talking about dismantling policies
the democrats in this country are
talking about creating lists of people
who support president trump
it's it's you know the cities washington
dc new york city all these big cities
weren't boarded up because it was trump
supporters that were going to riot and
loot and vandalize and destroy property
it was the left and that gets close to
his argument
you're also seeing donald trump
supporters tooled up with weapons on the
street as well are you not
in in texas right there was yeah which
they are legal and they were allowed to
do
there's a big difference between being
able to exercise your second amendment
right here in this country
without infringing on somebody else and
destroying and looting and vandalizing
property
that's you know so again i get it you
want to justify this but the reality is
the boarding up of buildings of
protection the police on every corner it
wasn't because of donald trump
all of these things that occurred prior
to election day you haven't seen the 72
million people that supported donald
trump go out there
and loot and riot and destroy and
vandalize that was the left that was
threatening to do that
not the right you did see people trying
to stop counting though didn't you
didn't what you saw people trying to
stop the counting process
no if anything they're asking it to all
the people who stopped the counting
process were in philadelphia and major
strongholds in the democratic party
they literally stopped counting in
philadelphia and went home they stopped
counting in other places in georgia
stop the protest process did we not see
that in detroit michigan
i i'm unaware of that i do know that
they stopped counting ballots
during the night on election night in
philadelphia and went home for no
explained reason
and nobody to this day has figured out
why that happened
and that's occurred in several places
they have been locked out of places to
observe the recount in several places
that they've had to seek court orders to
get back in on so i mean
you know again i i get the the goal here
which is to justify what's happening
but at the end of the day it's kind of
interesting that the
the folks in the media are allowing this
to occur by folks on the left and with
with reckless abandon no a sense of
accountability
what is the first job for
president-elect biden
or donald trump if he does retain
the white house what should their first
their number one job be as we head into
2021
well i think number one is continue to
get a hold of the coronavirus we've seen
the
a really positive development with this
vaccine so it's going to be to
to develop i mean to execute and deploy
the vaccine to the nation to make sure
that
obviously the first responders and
people who are vulnerable get it first
and the rest of america
and obviously ensure that we continue to
open the economy and make sure that
people can get back to work
sure spicer but i think they go hand in
hand sean spicer appreciate your time
thank you for joining us from this
afternoon thank you